[Música]
Corea del Sur reportó el lanzamiento de
dos nuevos misiles de corto alcance por
parte de Corea del Norte esto después de
que pyongyang lanzara un misil que
sobrevoló Japón y Estados Unidos y seúl
contestarán con lanzamientos en el mar
del este en el Consejo de Seguridad de
la ONU Washington acusó a Rusia y a
China de apoyar a Kim Jong
la OPEP más aprieta el Grifo la alianza
de países exportadores de petróleo
acordó reducir su producción de crudo en
dos millones de barriles diarios la
decisión se da en medio de una crisis
energética que golpea principalmente a
Europa a raíz de la guerra en Ucrania
Estados Unidos reaccionó asegurando que
el bloque se alineó con Rusia tenemos
análisis
Vladimir Putin firmó un decreto que
designa a la central nuclear de Sa
polilla la más grande de Europa como
propiedad Federal rusa esto Después de
firmar la ley de anexión de los
territorios ocupados entre tanto Ucrania
sigue quitándole terreno a las tropas
rusas el presidente celensky confirmó la
liberación de otros tres asentamientos
en
Hola Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en France 24 lo saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en Asia porque se
mantienen las tensiones en la Península
coreana Corea del Sur reportó que su
vecino del Norte lanzó otros dos nuevos
misiles balísticos de corto alcance
hacia el mar de Japón y que habrían sido
disparados desde pyongyang la situación
se da justo cuando las fuerzas de seúl y
Washington realizaban ejercicios
conjuntos en territorios surcoreano y un
día después de que otro misil norcoreano
sobrevolar a territorio japonés según el
Ministerio de defensa nipón los misiles
norcoreanos cubrieron un Rango de 800
kilómetros con trayectoria irregular los
recientes y continuos lanzamientos por
parte de pyongyang fueron tema central
de una reunión del Consejo de Seguridad
de la ONU y en la que Rusia y China se
abstuvieron de criticar al líder
norcoreano Kim Jong Estados Unidos acusó
a estos países de apoyar a Corea del
Norte
la República popular democrática de
Corea ha disfrutado de la protección
general de dos miembros de este consejo
estos dos miembros han hecho todo lo
posible para justificar sus repetidas
provocaciones y Bloquear todo intento de
actualizar el régimen de sanciones en
resumen dos miembros permanentes del
Consejo de Seguridad han habilitado a
Kim Jong
able
el Consejo de Seguridad debe desempeñar
un papel constructivo en el tema de la
Península de Corea en lugar de depender
únicamente de una fuerte retórica
opresión las discusiones y
deliberaciones del Consejo deben
contribuir a la distensión en lugar de
alimentar la escalada deben promover la
reanudación del diálogo en lugar de
ampliar las diferencias y forjar la
unidad en lugar de crear divisiones
la alianza de la OPEP más que incluye
Arabia Saudita y Rusia decidió reducir
su producción de crudo en millones de
barriles diarios a sus de sus cuotas a
partir de noviembre la medida se tomó
durante una reunión que se llevó a cabo
en Viena el primer encuentro presencial
del grupo desde el inicio de la pandemia
de Kobe 19 la medida supone el mayor
recorte desde 2020 y se traduce en
mayores precios de crudo lo que podría
darle otro golpe a la economía mundial
en medio de los temores de una crisis
energética derivada de la guerra en
Ucrania sin embargo el impacto Debería
ser menor debido a que los países de la
alianza ya estaban bombeando menos de la
cuota establecida para hablar de este
tema saludamos en Bogotá Colombia a Luis
Pacheco les analista petrolero y
académico no residente del biker
institute rice University en Houston
Texas señor Pacheco Bienvenido a flash
24 Estados Unidos respondió esta medida
diciendo que la OPEP o diciendo que esta
Alianza estaba alineándose con Rusia
realmente podría tratarse de una
decisión política
Bueno si hablar del petróleo y decir que
no es político es ser bastante
ingenuo pero obviamente tiene este
componente pero tiene también el
componente de la OPEP gloss de tratar de
defender los precios de Cara a lo que
ellos ven como una potenciación
potencial recesión como tu bien
apuntastes es una mensaje más que todo
nominal porque como tú bien dijistes No
están produciendo lo que deberían
producir y de hecho al decir que van a
recortar dos millones versos las cuotas
de agosto lo que están es sincerando la
incapacidad del grupo en este momento de
producir esos voluntarios
ahora cuál es el impacto que esta medida
puede tener por ejemplo para Estados
Unidos y sobre todo para yo bailén justo
un mes de las elecciones de medio
término
eso también Es una excelente pregunta
los precios del petróleo ya venían
subiendo el mercado había factorizado el
hecho de que ese recorte iba a ocurrir
así si fuera nominal
Porque además
la OPEP pros lo que está diciendo es yo
controlo el mercado de petróleo ya que
el otro mayor productor que es los
Estados Unidos no está respondiendo
debido a razones de política interna en
primer lugar y de razones
financieras en segundo lugar eso
Obviamente que va a afectar los precios
de la gasolina y los precios de la
gasolina en el sistema electoral
norteamericano que es el que viene ahora
en noviembre tiene un efecto quizás
exagerado pero lo tienen entonces para
la administración bailen es un es un
golpe
señor Pacheco ya lo decía usted afecta
el precio de la gasolina de los
estadounidenses pero Cómo afecta esto el
bolsillo de la población en general esto
teniendo en cuenta la situación
energética que está afectando
principalmente a Europa y que se deriva
de la guerra en Ucrania y las tensiones
con Rusia
Sí bueno deriva de la atención es con
Rusia pero también deriva de políticas
asociadas a desincentivar inversiones En
el mercado fósiles pero para responder
tu pregunta directamente
es el precio de los combustibles tiene
un impacto directo en casi toda la
economía porque el transporte se ve
afectado la generación de la
electricidad se ve afectada el precio
del gas que también va en paralelo al
del petróleo por razones similares
también afecta toda la economía Entonces
al final del día el precio de la energía
en una sociedad moderna se ve reflejado
en lo que el consumidor paga en cada uno
y todos estos productos
Luis Pacheco analista petrolero Gracias
por acompañarnos aquí en Flash 24
y cambiamos de tema y pasamos a las
noticias de la guerra en Ucrania el
presidente Vladimir Putin firmó un
documento con el que oficializa el
control de la planta de saborilla por
parte de la federación rusa la central
se encuentra en una de las regiones de
sancionadas unilateralmente por Moscú
después de haber celebrado referéndums
calificados por la comunidad
internacional como ilegales el director
del organismo internacional de energía
atómica Rafael grossi dijo que estará en
kiev esta semana y luego en Rusia para
continuar las conversaciones en torno a
una zona de protección alrededor de la
planta en medio de los temores sobre un
eventual accidente radioactivo por los
combates entre tropas rusas y ucranianas
Mientras tanto en el terreno continúan
los ataques cruzados con el ejército
atacando a la región de kiev y Ucrania
certificando sus avances militares Marta
Moya con los detalles
las fronteras rusas según la propia
Rusia se expanden tras la luz verde de
la duma y el senado este miércoles el
presidente Vladimir Putin firmó el
decreto que confirma la anexión de la
regiones de donets lugans jerson aunque
los combates siguen en los territorios
anexados el kremlin sostiene que seguirá
preguntando a la población sobre su
nuevo estatus
algunos territorios serán recuperados
Seguiremos consultando con la población
de allí que desee vivir junto a Rusia
en el marco de su escalada Putin también
anunció que se modificó el decreto de la
movilización parcial mediante la que
Moscú refuerza con 300.000 reservistas
el frente de batalla una cuestión
polémica al interno de la nación y que
ha generado malestar entre la sociedad
todo ello mientras el gobierno sigue
entrenando y enviando tropas a Ucrania
el Ministerio de defensa ha informado
que no es necesario el reclutamiento
para una serie de categorías de nuestros
ciudadanos como parte del esfuerzo de la
movilización y los se enumeró sin
embargo los cambios relevantes al marco
legal no Se realizaron a tiempo entonces
hemos tenido que hacer ajustes a este
documento En consecuencia ya emitió un
decreto hoy y ya se firmó en el terreno
la ofensiva no se detiene mientras el
ejército ruso ataca la región de kiev
con drones y dice repeler los ataques
ucranianos en gerson kiev sigue
justificando sus avances primero el
ejército ucraniano Está realizando un
avance bastante rápido y poderoso
alrededor de nuestro país como parte de
la actual operación de defensa decenas
de asentamientos ya han sido liberados
del falso referendo ruso esto en la
región de gerson pero también hay
avances en la región de harkiv la región
de Luján si la región de doniz en
paralelo la Unión Europea aprobó su
octavo paquete de sanciones contra Rusia
Entre ella se debate fijar el precio del
petróleo si la cantidad se fija con los
países del g7 y otras naciones en
Estados Unidos el presidente Joe biden
llegó a Florida para ser testigos de los
daños provocados por el huracán Ian
junto a su contradictor político y
potencial rival en las elecciones
presidenciales de 2024 el gobernador del
estado ron de santis El mandatario se
mostró comprometido a destinar los
fondos necesarios para la recuperación
del estado que según dijo tardará años
los detalles de la jornada desde Fort
Lauderdale con nuestro corresponsal alto
nivelci
el presidente de Estados Unidos
ha visitado el área de Fort Myers en
Florida donde hace justo una semana pasó
el huracán Ian dejando un panorama
devastador el mandatario ha visto cómo
se están llevando a cabo las tareas de
rescate que es ahora mismo la prioridad
al tiempo que se siguen sumando más
muertes por esta catástrofe ya hay más
de un centenar de víctimas mortales
confirmadas pero se teme que sean muchas
más ya que aún no se ha podido llegar a
algunos lugares a pieden ha venido hasta
Florida con un objetivo el de mostrar el
compromiso del Gobierno Federal de
destinar todos los recursos que sean
necesarios para reconstruir esta zona
cuanto antes también ha prometido ayudas
económicas para todos los damnificados
por el potente ciclón a través de la
agencia de manejo de emergencias una
visita Que obviamente también tiene un
trasfondo político y más cuando la
gestión del gobernador de Florida el
republicano ron de santis empieza a
estar dicho y es que algunas voces
críticas sostienen que no se llevaron a
cabo todos los protocolos necesarios de
seguridad para evacuar a la población ya
que muchos no Se tomaron en serio los
avisos de tormenta de santis se ha
defendido y ha dicho que se cumplieron
con todos los mecanismos pero es que la
gestión de esta crisis puede tener
consecuencias políticas y más teniendo
en cuenta que el nombre de ron de santis
cada vez suena con más fuerza como
posible candidato presidencial
republicano para las elecciones
generales de 2024 en Estados Unidos
además ha sido muy crítico con la
gestión de biden al frente de la Casa
Blanca por eso Muchos consideran que
dependiendo del trabajo que se haga
ahora en cuanto a la reconstrucción
puede beneficiar o perjudicar las
aspiraciones políticas de ambos
el corte de un mechón de pelo se ha
convertido en un símbolo de apoyo a las
mujeres iraníes incluso figuras
políticas y celebridades se han Unido al
movimiento de solidaridad tras la muerte
de maxa a mini el fallecimiento de la
joven de 22 años tras haber sido
arrestada por la policía de la molar de
la moral desató una ola de protestas en
la República islámica las autoridades de
ese país señalan una supuesta
conspiración extranjera más detalles en
el siguiente informe
un gesto de protesta que ya es mundial
desde esta eurodiputada sueca
incondicional e inmediato de toda la
violencia contra las mujeres y los
hombres en Irán hasta que Irán sea libre
nuestra Furia será más grande que la de
los opresores hasta que las mujeres
dirán sean libres yin
estaremos con ustedes están
allí
ya está celebridades como la actriz
francesa Juliette binoche al ritmo de
bella Ciao
la solidaridad se representa a través
del corte de un mechón de pelo esto en
las protestas antigubernamentales más
grandes en décadas en irán con mujeres y
estudiantes como protagonistas
desafiando la represión e incluso
retirándose el jillab estas continúan
pero también contra manifestaciones
como esta Pro gubernamenta lente eran la
capital este miércoles
fue la excusa de nuestros enemigos para
destruir nuestra unidad Mientras todos
hemos vivido juntos con diferentes
creencias y nunca fue un problema
Estados Unidos e Israel son la raíz de
todos estos disturbios solo porque no
pueden luchar contra nosotros están
tratando de atacarnos creando problemas
internos el martes es el presidente
iraní ebrahimra Easy habló de
Conspiración de los enemigos y mientras
las organizaciones registran decenas de
fallecidos desde el inicio de las
protestas Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea estudian sanciones
[Aplausos]
los científicos Caroline inventó si
mortín Medal y Barry Shark Paul son los
ganadores del premio Nobel de química
por el desarrollo de la química del
click que ha permitido mejorar la
orientación de los productos
farmacéuticos contra el cáncer la
química del clic se utiliza en el
desarrollo de los productos
farmacéuticos para mapear el ADN y crear
materiales que sean más adecuados para
su propósito usando reacciones
biotogonales La Academia sueca recordó
que durante mucho tiempo los químicos se
han visto impulsados por el deseo de
construir moléculas cada vez más
complicadas en la investigación
farmacéutica esto a menudo ha
involucrado la recreación artificial de
moléculas naturales con propiedades
medicinales
hasta que este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos continúen con toda nuestra
programación
[Música]